tres años participe en una campaña
mundial
se llamaba plástica online consistía en
que durante todo julio se comprometía a
no usar plástico de los saludos
desde entonces de querer es algo con
clásicas cañitas
hace dos años
[Música]
el año pasado
este año me he comprometido a dejar de
consumir tanta carne roja y vamos a
preferir comprar los productos que estén
elaborados localmente
hago la diferencia
[Música]
y aparte puede parecer insignificante
pero es mi contribución individual lo
que está a mi alcance
todos hemos escuchado hablar de
problemas ambientales enfrentando el
planeta
la contaminación del aire de las
ciudades
la deforestación de los bosques
tropicales
la acumulación de micro plásticos en los
océanos
las gentes de agua el exceso de bajo
juramente la pérdida de la biodiversidad
todos hemos escuchado hablar de cambios
dinámicos
de su existencia cada vez que tenemos
una opción pero realmente entendemos lo
que es el cambio climático
cuando los rayos del sol irán a la
tierra son servidos en la atmósfera
sólo gases de efecto invernadero
esos rayos absorbidos calientan el aire
generando condiciones apropiadas para la
vida
podemos decir entonces que estos gases
de efecto invernadero actúan como una
mantita
genera que estas condiciones apropiadas
para personas
los principales gases de efecto
invernadero como el dióxido de carbono
ventaja
se genera naturalmente por algunos
procesos que suceden
por ejemplo la respiración de los seres
vivos con las erupciones volcánicas
entonces podemos decir el efecto
invernadero tienen algo no por el
contrario es natural y es necesario sino
saber entender entonces el cambio
climático como lo dice su nombre el
cambio climático es una alteración del
comportamiento naturales del clima
se produce con una mayor acumulación de
estos gases de efecto invernadero en la
atmósfera y estos provienen de las
actividades de los seres humanos
entonces podemos entender que lo que se
ha comprendido
recordá partes de las emisiones
verdaderos producidos por el nombre de
la comisión de
los combustibles fósiles que usamos para
generar energía
esto es el carbón y el gas para generar
y la gasolina que usamos en los
vehículos ya sea lo que nos guste
los aviones los
no paramos
el otro 25% de las decisiones no generan
otros sectores
vienen de la agricultura y la ganadería
de los procesos industriales del manejo
de la basura y de la deforestación
estoy contando en el inventario
todo lo dice la ciencia
el pan elemental de cambio climático
también conocido como el imss es un
grupo de científicos y expertos que ha
sido convocada por las naciones unidades
en un informe oficial que se publicaron
a fines del 2018 el ipc se nos dicen que
tenemos acumulados a la fecha en la
atmósfera de la tierra tantos gases de
efecto invernadero que han logrado
incrementar la temperatura en un grado
centígrado
además nos advierte que si no recortamos
las emisiones estamos generando
este incremento de temperatura supera
los 3 grados centígrados
ustedes dirán pero 3 grados centígrados
un poquito más
pensemos en lo que significa y cómo
percibimos nosotros los tres grados
centígrados
y pasar de estar sanos con 37 grados
hasta con una fiebre de 40 o más
recuerdan cuando más se sintieron la
última vez que tuvieron
se imaginan así siempre
como se traduce en una fiebre en el
planeta
el rendimiento de hielo de los juegos y
de los glaciares
tormentas y huracanes cada vez más
frecuentes y cada vez más fuertes
olas de calor y temperaturas extremas
incremento en el nivel del mar que
afectan islas y ciudades costeras
avalanchas inundaciones inciertos
forestales que afectan la
infraestructura que nosotros usamos
todos los días
repitiendo el anterior
pérdidas en la producción agrícola y en
los recursos pesqueros que pone en
riesgo la seguridad alimentaria de todos
tal cual
y ahora el cambio climático parecía la
'roja' del futuro reporte
no estamos recibiendo los primeros
síntomas de esta textura que ya está
entiendo el capital
todos podemos recordar probablemente
como 20 ciento menos del niño del año
días
si seguimos las noticias internacionales
nos hemos estado escuchando por ejemplo
divulgando en septiembre de este año la
razón con la isla de abajo
también podemos haber escuchado de las
olas de calor en europa que han llegado
o de los incendios forestales
descontrolados que intentas y australia
o de las inundaciones que hace unos días
nos han llegado las noticias de
creencias
el cambio climático
nos podemos pasar horas hablando de
todos los impactos
esto nos dejaría todos trabajos
yo quiero que sabemos sabiendo cuáles
son las cosas
son también muy importantes y tenemos
que tomarlos
el primero es nos tenemos que adaptar
debemos estar preparados para enfrentar
estos efectos que nos van a llegar
inevitablemente
y segundo tenemos que reducir nuestras
emisiones de gases
para el 2030 tenemos que haber reducido
casi a la mitad las emisiones que
estamos generando
además para el 2050 tenemos que llegar a
ser
con esto lograríamos el incremento de
temperatura supere 2.5
o sea vamos a tener solamente eso
pero vamos a limitarnos
porque requiere que nos tomemos que
tengamos cambios conformacionales en la
manera como tenemos
y además lo más importante de todo es
que requiere de la participación de
todos
a nivel global
tenemos un punto de partida importante
en el año 2015 195 países aprobaron el
acuerdo
el acuerdo
vamos a lograr
mantendremos en la meta el punto sino
que plantea
para eso los países cada uno de los
países tiene que definir cuándo hacer
con su contribución en términos de
reducción de emisiones o de adaptación
a la fecha la mayoría de países ya han
anunciado
son suficientes lamentablemente nos
falta mucho todavía
pero de este punto los vídeos de los
rescatados es que hemos logrado un hito
muy importante que es que todos nos
pongamos de acuerdo en un problema
importante como el de cristal
en esta contribución que tiene el valor
a nivel país los gobiernos tienen que
reformular sus modelos de desarrollo
incorporando las variables climáticas y
ambientales sobre esto diseñar leyes
políticas y planes y llevar hacia
adelante acciones concretas que nos
permitan llegar a la meta sus metas
las metas propias del país o incluso más
allá
cosas como
generar la electricidad con fuentes
renovables conviviendo con el reemplazo
de los combustibles
promover el uso de vehículos eléctricos
incrementar las áreas naturales
protegidas generar extras de folios de
agua suficientes y adecuados
para los cambios
las opciones son muchas en base a su
propia nivel
en la contribución del nivel
a nivel de ciudades es necesario diseñar
el sistema de transporte público que nos
permita movilizar a muchas personas
línea de buses o de metros
también se pueden habilitar ciclovías
peatonales que le permitan a los
ciudadanos usar otros medios de
transporte
incrementar las áreas debes tener
problemas de manejo eficiente de
vertidos todo está a nivel de ciudad el
sector privada privados es un actor muy
importante las empresas existentes
pueden medir su huella de carbono ser
consciente del impacto que está en
generador y el tomar medidas para
reducirlo
los emprendedores pueden diseñar modelos
de negocio innovadores los bancos pueden
invertir en proyectos que apuesten por
la sostenibilidad
esto es la contribución del sector
privado
llegamos finalmente a la población
general a nosotros nos toca ser
responsables con nuestras decisiones y
nuestras acciones en las cosas que
hacemos en el día a día
tratemos de evitar pensar en más de lo
necesario obtenemos por medios
alternativos
y me temo desperdiciar comida
ahora hemos el agua cuando estamos
estudiando
prioricemos comprar productos que sean
ambientalmente responsables
queremos apoyar proyectos de
conservación
opciones para nosotros hay muchos que es
importante para nosotros mantenemos
informados y vigilantes
muy importante también es que seamos
responsables al momento de decidir qué
universidad
esta es la contribución que tenemos
nosotros como personas
el cambio climático es una crisis global
qué tal
es ahora necesitamos una acción
climática urgente y además muy ambiciosa
todos nosotros tenemos un producto yo me
he comprometido
a consumir cada vez menos carne todos
a usar cada vez medio indicador
en mi contribución y espero poder leer
un mercado
ustedes a que te vas a encontrar
[Aplausos]